we can go ahead and start
uh can you see my screen
hi can you see my screen yep
yep that's great okay uh
i'll begin um
oh okay yeah i can introduce you thanks
for giving this talk and
uh we'll talk about phase transitions
for the detecting
latent geometry and random graphs
uh please go ahead and start
um yeah i'll be as has mentioned i'll be
talking about uh
phase transition for uh detecting latent
geometry and random graphs
uh this is joint work with my uh lab
mate
matt brennan and my advisor guy bresler
okay um let me first define what this
whole talk is going to be about it
is going to be about random geometric
graphs
which we'll denote by rgg
more specifically we'll denote it as rgg
of n d p
okay uh we'll consider n to be the set
of vertices
and d is the latent dimension
okay p is the probability
of including an edge
how do we generate random graphs from
this model
we first pick x1 to
xn to be iid
uniform over the sphere
in uh embedded in rd and
i'll let e i j
sorry what just happened
let eij
um be the indicator that
um let's say i comma the edge i comma j
belongs to the edge set of the random
graph g
then uh we will write the following
expression for eij which defines them
is equal to 1 if
uh the distance between x i and x j
is less than or equal to some tau p
comma d
and zero otherwise
since all these points are on the sphere
we can easily convert it to
a more convenient notation involving the
inner products that is we can write it
as
one if the inner product between x i
comma
x j is greater than or equal to t p d
which is a quantity we will be using a
lot
and zero otherwise
uh the main questions uh we kind of ask
uh in this is uh
how is it different from erdospheny
random graphs
okay um in fact uh we want to
uh as be more specific that is
uh given n comma p n
uh sequence of number of vertices and
the edge inclusion probabilities
for n belongs to n the question is
how should
our d scale has a function of l
so that
the total variation distance between r g
g
of n d n p n
comma g of n comma p n
converges to zero
uh
um this is as n tends to infinity
and there so this basically
uh gives us a bounce on statistical
testability
that is if limit as n tends to infinity
uh the total variation distance between
these two models converges to zero
then with a single sample we cannot
distinguish between
our random geometry graphs and um uh
air does for any random graphs and this
will be
uh the topic of our discussion today
uh this is not the most general form of
random graphs with latent geometry
uh in the most general general case we
pick
uh the latent variables x1 to xn
corresponding
each of them corresponding to a vertex
iid from some matrix
matrix space s comma m where s is some
set and m is the metric
uh we join uh nodes i and j
if the distance between them
is less than or equal to tau tau is some
threshold we set
so that the edge inclusion probability
is
let's say p and it is
zero otherwise the geometry here which
we refer to
is provided by the latent matrix space s
comma m
uh these matrix spaces need not be like
rd with euclidean metric it can be more
funky spaces
which which lead us to an example like a
random intersection graph
uh we i'll just mention this very very
briefly
and we study these objects uh more
clearly in um
in our paper and we refer you to the
paper for more information
okay how do we generate rig we pick x1
to
xn to be iid
random subsets
of let's say a universe set d
and e i j the edge indicator
is 1 if x i intersection x j
is not a null set and 0 otherwise
how we see this is that 1 to n are
people
and the set d is the set of
activities that people are interested in
and
suppose x i in i i person i
involves in the activities given by the
set x i
um i and j know each other if uh they
have a common activity and that's how we
construct this social network sort of
graph
uh for more details on this please refer
to our
uh paper
referring to uh maybe a previous slide
if you can what
exactly p is oh p is
equal to the probability that e i j
equals one
uh does that clear it up
okay uh yes i think so okay
okay so yeah that is a that is something
we fix
beforehand and then we play around with
the rest of the things like latent
dimension
um okay so
we will delve deeper into rtgs
okay now
uh we we let me recall the definition
real quickly again
we had x1 to xn to be iid
uniform on sd minus 1
that is the sphere in rd
and eij is the indicator that
i and jth vertex have an edge
is equal to 1 if
the inner product x i comma x j
is at least t p comma d and
0 otherwise now
as i just mentioned p a t p d
is set such that p is equal to
probability of
e i j greater than or e e i j equals 1
which is equal to probability of
t p d is less than or equal to
x i comma x j
okay um now uh we want to uh test this
versus let we call this model
rgg of ndp
and we want to test this against the
erdos-renyi random graphs the g of
n comma p where each edge is
either included included with iid with
probability
p and this is the most studied form of
model of random graphs
okay we want to compare this
specifically in the total variation
distance
let me review some literature regarding
this
okay the one of the first papers on this
topic
was by which considers this exact
problem
is by debroy and
others they consider this as a side
problem in the paper which
mainly involved counting cliques in
these
random geometric graphs this was in
2011.
they use beriasin type clts to show that
when d is much larger than 2 to the
omega of n
then this implies uh tv convergence
as n tends to infinity
okay so this is via very seen type clt
and variation type clts have the
error rates of the order 1 over square
root d for
probability of certain kinds of sets and
in this case convex sets
and and each graph has exponentially
small probability in either model
so to be able to approximate
probabilities to exponentially small in
n
we need d to be at least 2 to the omega
n and that's where the
bad bounds come from this was improved
upon by
bubeck and others
in the 2016 paper which showed that when
d
is much larger than n cube this implies
db convergence
okay and uh we they also showed that
this is tight
when p is a fixed constant p
p is a fixed constant independent of n
okay ah that is there is a statistical
test
which can which succeeds with
probability close to 1
when d is less than or equal to n cubed
ah with high probability when d is less
than or equal to
um n cube so what is this test
um this this test just counts the number
of triangles sine triangles
in uh in random geometric graphs
compared to
erdogany random graph to give you some
intuition as to
why this test might work let me give you
an exaggerated example of a random
geometric graph
in two dimensions
suppose we have x1 x2
and x3
and suppose we are given that x1 and x2
are close enough to each other so that
they have an
edge and x 1 and x 3 are close enough so
that
they have an edge between them then by
triangle inequality
x2 and x3 must also be close to each
other
so the there is a higher probability
that there might exist
an edge between these two
okay so what this implies is that
there are larger number of triangles
compared to
gnp
and um yeah so the the statistical test
they
give it succeeds when d is much smaller
than n cube in the dense case
is exactly based on this such a triangle
counting
um but that is centered triangles
because we want to reduce the variance
in the number of triangles
so and they use the statistics to show
that um i should give a test which
succeeds with
high probability and there um
what we are interested in is in how they
prove the convergence in total variation
distance
when d is much larger than n cube this
proceeds
by a random matrix theory uh i should
also mention that
the proof of the of this is
actually also implied by a prior result
of
uh jiang and lee
which was which came out in 2015 but
they did not think about
the random geometric graph problem and
go back at all
came up with that proof independently of
the giang and lee
results so how is this
total variation convergence proved and
what are the
problems of extending extending it to
other cases
okay so um how do we prove
prove this we first note that if we have
rgg of n
d p this can be obtained as a
thresholding
of a certain random matrix that is the
wish heart matrix
i've introduced a lot of notation here
here w
is a vishart matrix
with of size n by n and with
d degrees of freedom we can see by the
structure of the wish heart matrix that
this must this must actually correspond
to
the the random geometric graph when we
pick
t to be the function t of x is equal to
1 of x greater than or equal to dpd
that is we take a wishart matrix and
threshold
each of its entries by tpd and we
obtain the approximately obtain the
adjacency matrix of the random geometric
graph
one thing which where it actually
differs is that wishart matrix contains
gaussians or the inner products of
gaussian gaussian vectors
but we are looking at distributions on
the sphere
but distribution uniform distribution on
the sphere looks approximately like
high dimensional gaussian so it
shouldn't matter too much
and we can make this more rigorous okay
and g of n comma p
can be similarly seen as a thresholding
of set
z where z is the
goe random z over square root d
where z is the gaussian orthogonal
ensemble of n
that is it is a symmetric matrix such
that z i j
is equal to z j i and each of them is
iid
normally distributed okay
now to show that to show that
there is a total variation convergence
between rgg and gnp
we just use the data processing
inequality
that is it is sufficient to show that
total total variation distance between
um
w and z over square root d
converges to zero and this can be done
quite easily because we know the
densities and uh
hence we can bound total variation
distance
why are the scale divergence using
pinskers inequality and
kl divergence can be evaluated because
we know the
radon nicotine derivatives explicitly
so um it turns out that this tends to
zero
if d is much larger than n cube
okay this seems like an almost complete
picture and
everything is already known but why do
we need our work
there is a catch here uh this threshold
is tight uh
only if p is
uh if we have dense regime that is if p
is theta one
um in fact it was uh conjectured in uh
bubeck
at all paper that when
p is equal to lambda over n which is the
sparse case which we are most interested
in in the case of random graphs
we have the the threshold was
conjectured to be
rd greater than log n cube
in fact this is when the triangle
statistic which works so well
in the dense regime fails and it can be
shown that all
small sub graph counts also converge and
are indistinguishable from
the those of erdost any random graphs
when d exceeds this
threshold so there is a huge gap between
the dense case and the sparse case
and doing something like a data
processing inequality loses a lot of
information because of
the thresholding and we cannot hope to
get such a bound
okay in fact it was not even known that
whether
if p n tends to 0 the rate becomes
strictly or better than n cube
that is the following question
okay in fact even this question was
unanswered
we in our work we answered this in the
positive
okay in fact we state the following main
theorem
uh suppose d
is much larger than n log n to the four
and d is much larger than
minimum not maximum but minimum of
uh n cube p um
log of 1 over p comma
n to the 7 over 2 p square
log n cube times square root
log 1 over p then
we have limit n tending to infinity
total variation distance between
r g g of n
d p comma g of n comma p
is equal to 0 and
so this let's look at some of the
special cases
when p is theta 1 then we recover the
standard guarantees recover the optimal
guarantees
that is d larger than n cube when p
is equal to lambda over n we get
the threshold to be d much larger than n
to the
3 over 2 log n to the 7 over 2
which is much better than d much larger
than n cube but
it's still much worse than the
conjectured bound of
log n cube okay
let me briefly describe our proof
technique
firstly we apply pinskers inequality
and conclude that to bound uh to show
that total variation distance converges
to zero it is sufficient to show that
the kl divergence
uh converges to zero and the second one
is to tensorize scale divergence
why do we need to tensor i scale
i'll get into why we need to tensorize
in a bit
and the third we'll use reverse
pinschers inequality
because we don't want to deal with too
much non-linearity
and the fourth step is to use
a finite definitely type result
ah result this implies
the threshold of d much larger than
n cube p okay uh henceforth i'll drop
all the logarithmic factors
uh which sort of are a new sense for
clear presentation
and i'll just keep the polynomial
factors and here there are
of course there are it is understood
that there are logarithmic factors here
okay and the fifth step is to boost this
bound
that is boost step four via a coupling
bound
this gives the bound of d much larger
than n to the seven over two
b square okay
and okay let me explain why we need to
do this
first of all we saw that these random
geometric graphs
are horribly dependent that is all
cycles
are if you have a consider any cycle in
it
it is not independent whether the cycle
is present or not or edges in a cycle
present or not is horribly dependent and
it is very hard to
describe the probability of a given
graph structure
so it would be more useful if we
consider
marginals or a single edge and the
dependencies that
arise for a single edge given the rest
of the graph
that is the probability of a given edge
being included given the rest of the
graph
and it turns out we can we have the
techniques to deal with such a quantity
and that's why we need to tensorize it
that is reduce our consideration from
total variation distance
to just considering uh
considering something over a single
coordinate and
we know that total variation distance
is not very it does not tensorize very
nicely but
kl divergence tensorizes very nicely by
which i mean that we can reduce the
kl divergence over the whole
distribution to the cable scale
divergence
of a single marginal to this to a single
margin
and that's why we do the tensorization
but uh kl divergence has log terms which
is
sort of unwieldy and two non-linear so
we use
reverse principles inequality after we
tensorize to get back to
sort of a tv square kind of distance
and and then rest of it is uh
is our results uh where we use finite
dfinity type
results and coupling bounds to actually
bound this reverse pin squares
inequality quantity
okay what i mean by finite definite
theorem is that
is that if we consider x to be uniform
over let's say sdn minus 1 and let's say
we write
x to be x1 to xd then
this result states that x1 to
xn looks approximately like
like a gaussian with covariance matrix i
over i
i n over d when n
is much less than d that is okay this is
what we mean by finite definite
theorem and this approximate
independence
is what helps us show that for instance
if we are given x1 x2 has an edge and x2
x3 has an edge
then the probability that x2 x
x1 x3 has an edge is also close to p and
that follows from this kind of
approximate independence as we will show
later
and the coupling bound is hard to
describe intuitively in words
i'll describe it mathematically in a bit
okay
let me state three information theory
lemmas
which um which are quite standard
the first is pinsker's inequality that
is suppose mu and your
probability measures over a space omega
then tv is bounded above by
square root of kl therefore it is
sufficient to prove that kl divergence
converges to 0.
in what follows we'll take mu to be
let's say rgg
and nu to be gnp
okay now the second one is kl
tensorization
when the base measure is a product
measure like nu is erdostini which is a
product measure
then the kl over the global
distributions
can be seen as a kl over the
local distributions that is if mu and nu
our probability measure over a product
set
omega to the m where m is a natural
number
and nu is a product measure that is a
product of new one to new m
in our case uh it this is a
this is a tensor product of m times of
bernoulli p
and omega in our case is
0 comma 1 which is indicator of each
edge being present
and m is equal to n c 2 which is the
maximum number of
pairs of vertices which can have an edge
between them
okay and then we can tensorize kl as
follows that is scale divergence between
mu and mu is less than or equal to this
quantity on the rhs
um let me explain the notation here here
um
g tilde e belongs to omega to the m
minus 1
which is all coordinates
of g other than e
what we see we see this in our context
as
the rest if we have an edge one comma
two then we consider
remo we don't look at that whether that
edge is present or not and we look at
the rest of the graph
and call that g tilde e and what this
means is that g
g tilde e is drawn from the
marginal distribution for the rest of
the graph
and what is mu e of
some dot g tilde e this
is the probability measure
of the eth coordinate g e conditional
that we are given the rest of the graph
g tilde e
okay um so this is quite
easy and then we take the expectation of
this and
the base measure here is mu e and uh
since new we don't need any conditioning
here because
nu e nu is a product measure in our case
uh nu e is equal to let's say bernoulli
of t
okay when we take mu to be the rgg
and we define some notation here we take
q e is equal to probability
that the edge e is present in the
random graph given the rest of the graph
this is again a random random variable
which is a function of
g tilde e
and then therefore this can this can be
written as
k l of mu given
nu is less than or equal to summation e
equals 1 to
n c 2 expectation of
g tilde e goes as mu tilde e k
l between bernoulli of qe
to bernoulli of p
okay this is the natural quantity which
arises here
now uh when when we have bernoullis uh
the kl divergence can be sharply bounded
given that we know the base measure
this is this will call the reverse
principal inequality
that is uh which basically shows that kl
divergence behaves quadratically near
its
near its close to its base measure that
is the kl divergence between
bernoulli q and bernoulli p is at most q
minus p
whole square over p so as long as p is
not zero we are fine
ok writing this down we know that in the
case of
a random geometric graph all edges
behave
similarly so without loss of generality
we know that
e all of these expectations are the same
so we fix the edge e to be
n minus 1 comma n without any loss of
generality
and and kl tensorization
and reverse principle inequality applied
to this case show that
kl divergence between rgg and g of n
comma p
is less than or equal to n c 2 times
expectation mod q e minus p
squared divided by p times 1 minus p
to remove some of the new sense aspects
in the expression we just write it as n
square over p
expectation mod q e minus p
whole square here the expectation of
g e goes as mu tilde e is assumed
when we say q e
okay so
ah okay so next we
we see that we have completed the first
step which is tensorization
uh which is pinsker and next we
tensorized and then we
looked at reverse principle inequality
now we need to use this finite
definitive theorem
to show the first bound and this is what
we are going at now
okay first um the the
what what kind of finite definitive
theorem do we have in mind
we want to show that mod
qe minus p is less than or equal to
p square root of n over d with
probability
at least uh let's say 1 minus 1 over
n to the 100 when d let's say is much
larger than
n log n to the four
okay so okay let's say that we were able
to show this
let's go back to our reverse principle
inequality
which we got for kl divergence and plug
this in and see that we get the first
bound
we saw that kl between mu to nu
was less than or equal to n square over
p times
expectation mod q e minus p squared
since this low probability set is very
very
small as small as any arbitrary inverse
polynomial
uh we can just write this as less than
or equal to
n square over p writing this here times
p
square times n over d which is equal to
n cube p over d therefore
d much larger than n cube p implies
convergence
okay um i spent some time proving this
result
um to prove this we look at gram-schmidt
orthonormalization
uh so we we have already assumed that d
is much larger than n um inner products
are unaffected by
any rotations even arbitrary rotations
which can depend on the points
themselves because
rotations preserve in our products so we
can without loss of generality
we can write x x 1 to be
x 1 x 1 1 comma 0 0
0 there are d minus 1 0's here
and x 2 is equal to x 2 1
x 2 2 0 dot 0
and similarly x n we can write it to be
x n one x and two
another dot x and n
zero zero zero and there are d minus n
zeros here
um okay fun fact here is that
uh by by the fundamental properties of
uh
high dimensional sphere the uniform
measure on the high dimensional sphere
is that x11 and
is approximately 1 so is let's say x i i
is also approximately equal to 1 with
very high probability
and x i j is very small
that is if you pick two points
independently uniformly at random from a
high dimensional sphere they are
approximately orthogonal
so this implies that x i j is of the
order one over
square root d okay
we recall that
q e is equal to probability that
um x n comma x n minus 1
is greater than or equal to t p d given
g tilde e okay
what does g tilde e depend on g tilde e
is nothing but thresholding of x i
x j for i comma j
not equal to and n minus 1 comma n
so this is actually because of the
non-linearity this is a very hard sigma
algebra to deal with
so we'll make we'll actually relax it a
bit make it finer
and then include more things into it so
we won't be bounding exactly qe but
we'll be bounding a finer version of qe
that is q naught
and it is actually after a bit of
technical effort it is
easy to show that even this by a
jensen's inequality
is just sufficient to prove overbound
is a probability of x n comma x n minus
1
is greater than or equal to t p d given
let's say x 1 to x n minus 1
and xn1 to
x and n minus 2.
uh if we can just compute explicitly
compute the
inner product here and show that
knowing these all these numbers will
give us the information on g tilde e but
not vice versa
and what is conspicuously missing here
is
x and n minus 1.
okay so when when we are given x
and n minus 1 then we know that x and 1
to x and n minus 1
are the first n minus 1 coordinates of x
n with respect to some random
orthonormal basis
which which is given to us by the
gram-schmidt orthonormalization of x 1
to x n minus 1.
so these coordinates must behave
approximately independent
and this is the definitive type result
i'll actually just wave my hand for a
bit and uh just
and leave out the rigorous proof of this
but we have an actual
actually uh elegant and beautiful proof
which uses a nice coupling argument to
quantify what we mean by approximately
independent and what we mean by
uh definitely type result but right now
i'll just wave my hand
okay we have an explicit expression for
the inner product between x n and x n
minus 1
in terms of a lot of quantities we
defined here
that is we have x n comma x n minus 1
is equal to x n minus 1 times
n minus 1 n minus 1 times x n n minus 1
plus summation j equals 1 to
n minus 1 x n minus 1 j
so x n minus 1 j and x and j
ah this is n minus 2 okay
so we've seen that
by concentration of measure phenomenon
this quantity
is of the order square root n over
d with high probability
which by which i mean it by at least 1
minus 1 over n to the 100
and x n minus 1 and n minus 1 is
approximately 1
okay so therefore this q uh this q
naught can be written as
probability that x n comma
n minus 1 is greater than or equal to d
p d
minus o of square root n
over d divided by 1 minus
small o of 1 given um
x1 to xn minus 1 comma
xn12 xn comma
n minus 2.
okay uh this of n over root d and small
of one are all dependent on these
random variables which are conditioned
here but with high probability they are
ignorable
we will call this quantity uh we
will call this quantity tpd prime
okay that is this is equal to
probability of
x n comma n minus 1 greater than or
equal to d p d
prime given all these
random variables now we go back and we
actually check
that by definition p is equal to
probability
that xn comma xn minus 1
is at least tpd
so this suggests us a natural way uh to
bound the difference between these two
and we know that the law of x and come x
n minus 1
is independent of whatever was being
conditioned
and we also know that tpd
minus dpd prime is less than or equal to
o of square root n over d
with high probability which is 1 minus 1
over
n to the 100 where the high probability
is over the what we are conditioning in
the background here
okay so therefore q naught
minus p is equal to
integral tpd prime to
tpd without loss of generality assuming
that tpd prime is less than tpd
psi d of t dt where
psi d is the density
of x and comma n minus 1
okay so to bound this quantity q naught
minus p it is sufficient to pound this
integral
we can actually show that this deviation
is not too much when d
is large enough so this can be
approximately written as
psi d of tpd
times mod dpd minus
tpd prime okay
and we can show y of easy calculus
on the distribution on on the density
function
that this is approximately equal to p
times
square root d log 1 over p
some constant times square root
n over d which is um
a p square root and
p square root n over d up to log factors
okay and
yeah p square root n over d with
high probability
and
this is exactly what we set out to prove
in the fourth
chapter that is this finite definiti
type result and this
uh finishes the third step in our proof
which gives us uh the first bound which
is b much
larger than n cube times b
okay so now we can we continue
our study here and we realize that we
can make it
much better this in in the case p is
uh when p is lambda over n this gives us
uh d larger than n cube n square
type threshold
we can actually do better than this by
adding one more step of
coupling here which i'll describe now
we had the following bound on the kl
divergence between mu and nu
which was that this is less than or
equal to n square over p
expectation of mod q e
minus p square
and where again let's recall qe is equal
to probability
that ge equals 1 given
the rest of the graph
now we had the definity type result
i'm sorry i don't know if d or f have to
be capital i forgot
um uh yeah so definitely type result
that which showed that
qe is uh minus p
is less than or equal to p times square
root of n over d
with very large probability
okay so instead of just applying it to
the whole expression
what we will do is we will show that kl
of
mu given nu is less than or equal to n
squared over p
times expectation of q e minus p
times q e minus p
which is less than or equal to n square
over p
times n square root n over d
sorry p square root
p square root n over d
times expectation mod
q e minus p
okay um so why did we do this we we just
applied this uh definitely type result
to one of the terms instead of both the
terms
why did we do this this because we can
actually write this
in as a closed form expression of
total variation distance between two
different measures
um what are those measures i'll describe
in a bit
of this is equal to n to the
5 over 2 over square root d
expectation mod
q e minus p
okay so we can actually show
that expectation of mod
u e minus p is equal to two times
p times total variation distance of
mu e plus comma mu tilde e plus and mu
tilde e
okay what is mu tilde e we are aware of
what mu tilde e
is which is marginal
uh distribution of g tilde e
and what is mu tilde e plus
this is the distribution this is the law
of
um conditional law of g tilde e given
g e equals to one in the in the random
geometric graph
we set the edge e to exist in the graph
and look at the distribution of the rest
of the graph
okay now continuing on with the previous
bound we have k l between
mu and nu is at most
n to the pi over 2 p over square root d
times total variation distance between
mu tilde e plus mu tilde
e now the once we have expressed this
as a total variation distance between
these two funky uh
probability measures uh we can
use a lot of tricks associated with how
we bound
total variation distances uh typically
that is we use coupling bound
that we suppose g tilde e is distributed
as
mu tilde e and
g tilde e plus is distributed as
mu tilde e plus over a common
probability space
okay then our tv of
mu tilde e plus comma mu tilde e can be
upper bounded by probability of
g tilde e not equal to g tilde e plus
so coming up with a nice
coupling between these two distributions
is sufficient
and i'll just construct the distribution
construct the coupling i have in mind
i think we are almost out of time so to
do this quickly
how do we uh we will use the convention
that um x1
let's say x
xn is equal to
en okay which is a standard basic basis
vector
almost surely this does not in any way
affect the
random graph if we choose the rest of
them to be uniformly at random
on the sphere because we can always
rotate it and without changing the
structure of the graph
okay we took we take xn to be en and
x1 to xn minus 1 to be
iid uniform
over s d minus 1
and we obtain g tilde e
by by thresholding
the inner products between x1 to xn okay
and um this gives us g tilde e which is
distributed
as mu tilde e plus oh sorry
uh distributed as uh mu tilde e
now how do we generate mu tilde e plus
now we will keep
the same x1 to xn minus 2
same as before
and we also fix xn to be equal to e n
almost surely same as before but instead
of x n minus 2 we
set it to be x n minus 1 plus
okay what is x n minus 1 plus we will
write it to be
let's say gamma plus times
e n plus square root of 1 minus gamma
plus
square divided by square root of 1 minus
x x n minus 1 comma
e n squared times
x n minus 1 minus e n
times x n minus 1 comma e n
okay we use this convention
where um where we basically take x n
minus 1
where okay i forgot to define the
notation here
here gamma plus is distributed as
x n minus 1 comma e n
given that x n minus 1 comma e n
is greater than or equal to t p d that
is before set
the edge uh between n minus 1 and n to
be
1 to exist in the graph okay
and then we go back and reverse engineer
the point x n minus 1 plus
so that this has gamma plus in the
direction of e
n making the edge to exist and the
and we rescale the perpendicular
component to x n
uh so that it is the same as it is in
the same direction as
x n minus 1. so this is sort of a
maximal coupling
now we need to bound
our probability that g tilde e is not
equal to g tilde e plus
okay when does this event happen
okay this happens when
for some uh j
equals 1 to n minus 2 we have
xn minus 1 comma xj is greater than or
equal to tpd
and xn minus 1 plus comma xj
is less than tpd or vice versa
why are the same coupling argument and
concentration of measure inequalities
we can show that x n minus 1 plus
minus x n minus 1 times
x j the norm of this is less than or
equal to
log n over d
with high probability high probability i
mean
at least one minus one over n to the
hundred
okay um so these are very close to each
other
and one of them has to be above the
threshold and one of them have to
has to be below the threshold let's draw
a picture
okay let's say we draw the density of of
the
of of the distribution of x n minus 1
comma x j
that is psi d and the threshold is here
that is t
p comma d and
okay so one of them is below the
threshold and one other is above the
threshold
but the distance between them is bounded
bounded by o of log n over d this in
particular
means that
x n minus 1 comma x j must belong to
this narrow band
narrowband of width of o of
log n over d
and this uh the the this event can only
happen
when x n minus 1 comma x j belongs to
this narrow band
what is the probability that the inner
product between x n minus 1 and x j
belongs to this narrow band
that is approximately equal to let's say
psi
d of t p d times
o of log n over d
which is approximately equal to p times
square root t over d
up to log factors which is p over square
root d
up to log factors now we did this for a
specific
j but we need to union bound over all j
equals 1 to n minus 2 therefore
probability of g tilde e not equal to
g tilde e plus is less than or equal to
np over square root d see up to
logarithmic factors
now we go back to our
previous equation way above
here which showed this
okay let me copy that back down
k l between mu and nu is less than or
equal to
n to the phi over 2 p over square root d
times probability of g tilde e is not
equal to g tilde e plus
which is less than or equal to n to the
7 over 2
p square over d this
implies that when d is
uh larger than or equal to uh
n to the 7 over 2 p square
implies convergence
which is what we set out to prove in
in here
and this um
this proves our theorem one
okay there are a lot of open questions
here
as in the con as in how to prove the
conjecture bound
we just proved that when p tends to zero
we can make
the threshold better than n cube but uh
even we do believe that the threshold is
sort of
log n cube there are many uh problems we
encounter when we try to
uh reach below uh when d is much smaller
than n
uh like uh for example the finite
definitely type result does not hold
because the dimension is already much
smaller than the number of points
and if you pick any d points they
already form a basis
and they're not even linearly
independent anymore so it's not clear
and that is
one of the bigger open problems uh
regarding this thank you
okay thanks so
um if there are any questions can use a
q
a or i can unmute anyone
and yeah i guess there's also
there will also be a break going on now
until 12 45
where pravesh kathari will tell us about
recent progress in algorithmic robust
statistics via the sum of squares method
hey